six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's see who else we can
squeeze in here why don't we go to the
seven seven three area code isn't that a
message is that Massachusetts seven
seven three oh I know seven seven four
is seven seven three where are you
calling from yeah I'm calling from
Chicago how's it going David all right
go ahead thank you so I want to bring up
a thought I've never really heard
anybody talk about before regarding
socialized medicine and then the long
term ramifications that I'd love to hear
Bernie talk about okay and those are
those are the difference it would make
on our auto insurance if we didn't have
to cover people's medical the difference
it would make
on our homeowners insurance we didn't
have to cover somebody falling off our
roof the insurance that kids have to get
to go to school and do sports it
wouldn't have to be paid for anymore
I mean insurance companies don't just
insure our health
they also insure our liability for other
people's medical bills right and they're
making a huge amount of money off of it
yeah now if you take it one step further
and we talk about litigation and the
attorneys that make money off of other
people suing people and insurance
companies for medical bills which would
not happen anymore because if you get
hurt in an accident
the only issue would be liability in
terms of negligence not liability in
terms of someone's medical condition or
whether or not they can walk anymore
that would be taken care of but did they
intentionally hurt you was there a
problem that you know with the roof that
you think someone should be punitive ly
damaged with but not medical claims
anymore I mean the difference yes we
might take a little bit more in taxes
but the savings system-wide that might
really put the insurance industry in
jeopardy if we thought about it I mean
that may be another reason that people
that the insurance companies are
fighting so tooth and nail to keep us
from being socialized is because if you
draw it out a little bit further think
of the ramifications of having our
medical cost covered very very
interesting yeah that is that is another
area altogether that we would have to
run the numbers on I've not seen an
analysis of that but at least
from from the the way you're presenting
it it's an excellent point and I
appreciate you making it so articulately
well I want this bright young man David
to pick up my torch because I'm an old
lady right right pick up this torch and
do this for me and let put this out
there let us start talking about the
real savings as a society we would have
if we just gave socialized medicine
chance yep absolutely health care
industry by the way I take care of dying
people I deal with tragedy every day
regarding the medical industry and we
just have to really think about how much
we would save think about all that
insurance you pay for your boat and for
everything absolutely wouldn't
absolutely because medical would be
covered thank you so much for the call
really really appreciate your insights
that's a good point something we should
look into more on that note we are out
of time my sincere apologies to the 20
people that are still waiting on hold we
just live calls are getting so popular
we can't keep up we will take calls
again and I appreciate everybody calling
in and sorry to everybody we did not get
to